so just to be absolutely clear this will
ya this will wipe everything it will
format the hard drive to the format
commonly used by Linux operating systems
and this will wipe everything out so
this will completely free I've been to
is not only open source which means that
the code is available for anyone to edit
in news based free so you can download
the straightaway so I mean for there's a
large portion of the Windows community
at the moment who are reluctant to move
forward to Windows 7 or Windows 8 now
especially I want to stay with their
familiar XP but support for XP is being
cut off soon and it can be quite
expensive to upgrade your operating
system you don't want in the first place
so the best alternative for many people
is to try it in the next version so
there are some versions of Linux that do
mimic XP very well in fact and although
you don't it may not necessarily VAX s
to all the same programs there's usually
a Linux alternative and it's completely
free of charge this is cost us nothing
to do it will cost nothing to leave to
life or the operating system and the
best thing about using a free and
open-source operating system is a lot of
software then also tends to be free and
open source
this laptop seems to be significantly
improved of it so I think we'll go ahead
install it we're still in our trial and
binti and but it conveniently just
dragged antic install but do buy on here
you get it here and in the taskbar they
put it in two places right next to each
other just in case you're really not
sure you want to install it okay right
so we can think of the options real
English should we continue
so install menu is really
straightforward nothing complicated so
this is prepared rest'll have been -
else to make sure you've got C even
checked you've got the correcting
quirements nothing goes wrong we're not
create the internet and so won't
downloading the updates but it will
install what's on the disk so we're
going to kill Windows we're completely
wiping it and replacing it with and burn
to but this is taking waits like oh hell
would you have been when this computer
came out in 2006
yeah well I'm 21 now so I would have
been around 13 which is probably
ironically the first time I was doing
this process to a machine yes this is
quite a quite an old piece of kit almost
a third of my age I don't think I had a
laptop till I was about 17 and even then
it was this big metal Patriot thing
about this thickness but it was made out
of metal for some reason and weighed
half a ton and died much sooner than
this this this has got a relatively
advanced into approach
thing had a via processor so this is a
really quite advanced machine in the
fact the screens they were so bright and
clear now is quite incredible it's very
high resolution for a laptop as well
this is honestly before the dark ages
where laptops got stuck in that horrible
or was it like the really weird postbox
screens that we're stuck with now for
stuck with now still what about
reliability because you know Windows
historically had people complaining
about Shrivers yes he's been pretty good
which is why people stand it what about
so this may start some sort of flame
wall here but I mean historically Linux
systems are much more stable and as I
mentioned earlier you've got Linux
systems running in datacenters and being
rebooted for decades and a lot of the
infrastructure of the country runs on
Linux systems and this being a long-term
support version of Ubuntu will be very
stable you're not going to have any
patches come down the break everything
suddenly all the patches that come to
this for the foreseeable future will be
verified to be stable and so on and so
forth
so you won't get any blue screen of
death that's all saying that happens and
quite often the really cool thing about
using Linux system is if you install an
update or you install a new program you
don't have to restart very rarely do you
ever have to restart from installing
something which is kind of an everyday
occurrence on Windows you can install
the onion stew when you program about it
asking you to restart you never have to
do that sort of thing in the next rainy
ball never is a strong word you
occasionally do but from day to day you
she won't really come into that problem
there's some drawbacks here and what
about using files from LibreOffice on
somewhere else there yeah so um liber
off it so because this is all free and
all doing relatively well I'm so
successful there are some kind of
passive aggressive attempts to put a
stop to it so especially with
LibreOffice you find that it has trouble
rendering the newer Microsoft Office
formats so if you're dealing with
formats from office 2013 or anything
docx
sometimes the fancier formatting options
don't come up perfectly and it does
mangle documents sometimes but for the
basics it works perfectly and if you
save to an older form it's kind of
saving to word formats of people with
word can open it and as long as you
slave to an older format it works really
well I think the fact that Microsoft
we're continuing to try and close off
their formats shows how friend they are
by Linux being free and good too
especially in the success of Amenti so
we've just got into the menu which lets
us decide what we want to do with the
previous operating system I'm going to
has detected that this system has been a
voluntary system on it it's giving some
options the first option basically will
make some room on the disks from free
space that's available and you will put
a bid to in there so then when we start
machine we can choose between going to
our previous operating system in this
case Windows XP or to go into a vintage
this is called dual booting and
basically means you have to open systems
I exist on the same machine they both
have their own files if I further phone
programs and you can choose which one to
run when you start up so this is really
useful for people say who say people
rely on a certain program on Windows but
they won't use them bun too so if you
rely on Adobe Photoshop and Adobe
Illustrator or video editing software
this is a very good route to takes you
can boot into that when you need it and
you can use a Linux system for you other
needs the second option which is what we
can do today is erase the disk and sort
of induce that wipes everything off
complete formats disk XP will be nowhere
to be seen
and number two will be the primary
operating system we won't have dual
booting we'll just have the one machine
and then something else this George
people have to worry about this this
puts you into the partition manager
which will actually do these things
manually yourself so let's do a race
disk and install Ubuntu it just goes
through to clarify which hard drive we
want it just warns us here again what
exactly is going to happen so for
petitions will be deleted so this has
four because this a machine has quite
nifty feature was actually another
operating system start installed on it
which is kind of a media operating
system so you can bypass Windows and
tidy and boot strain to the media center
and we're also going to nuke that so
several operating systems are being
destroyed in this process so in store
now so now it's going for the installing
so there's a little progress bar at the
bottom which tells you exactly what's
happening and in the meantime it's going
to some options to go through so now
I've been what it's installing it's
asking us select or timezone this map is
really fiddly located London okay so we
set to London and continue there's quite
good install process it doesn't ask you
loads of questions and then go through
and then you just sit there wait for the
finish you actually do order the options
while it's installing so you're not
wasting any time
okay so just sup the user account going
through
okay the notice installing and while you
wait for the installation it gives you
some muscle tricks and tips and how to
get more software and edit photos and
how to set up your personal cloud and
what sort of stuff just keep you amused
while it's installing we shouldn't take
too long and I mean this is not your
machine this is ticking on very nice
thing going pretty quick if you do
anything new work put it be
lightning-fast let me do it in from an
SSD or modify instant okay okay so this
kind of goes through some of the key
features so talks about the software
Center now we wait
but one thing that differentiates this
from star next P system is once it's a
started up once you get desktop you
genuinely have the desktop you may have
noticed before with your Windows systems
when you get to the desktop and you
think oh it's finally booted you go try
and do something and you set that wait
for another three or four minutes but
this is genuinely up we can open files
it's just stress it out a bit and open
load stuff in the taskbar I made a
mistake opening LibreOffice first which
was not gonna take a decade too low we
looked before in the Windows XP task
manager or should we have a little
comparison I've open system monitor just
a little poke around and LibreOffice is
loading the background so it's not a
direct comparison last time we were
extracting files here I just opened a
program but that reached a peak of about
four so fifty percent and now it's gone
back down and we're sitting on idle now
when this isn't it like a scientific
test but already the loads much lower
and as we're seeing here an idle the
load is about between five and eight
percent i'm good is a bit of a confused
operating system where it's trying to be
consumer friendly at the same time it's
still very much a hard school it systems
you still there's still a lot of actions
that need to take place in the command
line and a lot of those commands you
need to do don't con itself you can find
them online and copy and paste it
straight simple to do and but where it's
trying to be become this user friendly
mass-market system it's starting to
bring in nice graphical wrappers to
things so the how you
we typically install software is use the
command line you you have an apt-get
command you put in the name of the
software you want it installed so it
finds it they've written a packet earth
like a app storefront to this kind of
you get storefront face similar to any
normal app storefront so great over to
the itunes don't find this often and and
software on that has reviews and you
just click
it's done that's really easy you don't
mess around the command line you don't
have to worry if it's damaging the right
version all it would download the
version of your system
and it's all very very very simple very
easy not dissimilar to the pro the ease
of use of the process for Android and
iOS app stores but while that creature
comfort is in place you still have
access to the command lines more
advanced things and typically if you
start off if you're new to Linux you'll
find that there probably is times when
you need to copy and paste a command
line command off the web but as you go
about doing this and as you do it more
and more in those use over the years
without realizing it you'll start to
learn the command line and eventually
become comfortable in it and once you
become comfortable using the command
line it's a much more powerful way to
work
it's much quicker you get a lot more
power to manipulate exactly what's going
on you don't have to move the mouse
around a lot you're drifting from the
keyboard and that's what makes it so
popular with developers and IT
professionals is that once you get your
workflow set up once you get your
command step once you can use the
commands everything is so quick and so
effortless